This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. John Washington grew up with his family's stories of migration and escape, from hiding in train compartments and swimming across rivers to the airplane his mother took to leave Romania for the U.S. as a teenager. But these stories of forging out dangerously on your own, they seemed to him like tales from a distant past. But then I remember when I first confronted it personally, and that was in the mid-2000s. John was on a camping trip with a friend
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。约翰·华盛顿（John Washington）从小听着家人的迁徙与逃亡故事长大，从躲在火车车厢里、游过河流，到他母亲作为十几岁的少年坐飞机离开罗马尼亚前往美国。但这些独自一人踏上危险旅程的故事，在他看来就像是遥远过去的传说。不过，我依然记得自己第一次亲身面对这种情况的时候，那是在 2000 年代中期。当时约翰和一位朋友正在进行露营旅行
out in the Anza Borrego desert, just east of San Diego. This is 99PI producer Lash Madon, and they're going to take it from here. John and his buddy were driving down a dirt road looking for a place to camp. And we saw a young man step into the road from the shoulder and flag us down. At that point I didn't speak much Spanish at all. We tried to communicate with each other and we understood that he was a migrant and also realized where we were, which was about 15 miles north of the border wall over really
地点在圣迭戈以东的安扎-博雷戈沙漠。我是 99PI 的制作人拉什·马东（Lash Madon），接下来的节目由我们为您讲述。约翰和他的朋友正开着车行驶在一条土路上，寻找露营的地方。这时我们看到一个年轻人从路肩走到路上，向我们挥手求助。那时候我几乎完全不会说西班牙语。我们试着互相沟通，明白了他是一位移民，同时也意识到我们所在的位置——距离真正的南部边境墙以北约 15 英里，地形非常
rough terrain. And he was clearly very thirsty and not in great shape. They gave him some water, topped him off a couple times. The man then asked for a ride to the next town. And in that moment, John didn't know what to do. Because we knew that it was illegal, but we didn't really understand the implications of if we were to be caught, of what would happen. John knew that under federal law, it's illegal to help undocumented immigrants into the United States,
崎岖难行。而且他显然非常渴，状态很糟糕。他们给了他一些水，帮他把水壶加满了好几次。随后，这个男人请求搭车去下一个城镇。那一刻，约翰不知道该怎么办。因为我们知道这是非法的，但我们并不真正清楚如果被抓到会有什么后果、意味着什么。约翰知道，根据联邦法律，协助无证移民进入美国是违法的，
and that if he gave this man a ride, there was a chance he'd face a federal offense. So they wished him luck and went on their way, got back in their car and drove off. And then when we got to camp and we started unpacking, I think it hit me, and I was kind of horrified by what we had done. I said, oh my God, we left this young man who was in bad shape on the side of the road. And so we jumped back in the car and we drove back to try to find him,
如果他让这个人搭车，他可能会面临联邦指控。所以他们祝他好运，然后继续赶路，回到车里开走了。而当我们到达营地开始卸行李时，这件事才真正击中了我的内心，我对自己刚才做的事感到有点惊恐。我说，天哪，我们竟然把这个状况糟糕的年轻人留在了路边。于是我们又跳回车里，开车回去找他，
and we didn't find him, of course we didn't. And in the years and long time since then, there's been this slow, dawning realization that I acted in a really inhumane way. And yet, the entire force of the way that we structure society right now, especially in the United States, but many other places as well, was compelling me to act that way. It was criminalizing me, or would have criminalized me, for offering him the help that he needed.
当然，我们没有找到他，怎么可能找得到呢。在之后的岁月里，这种缓慢而逐渐清醒的认识油然而生：我的行为极其不人道。然而，我们目前构建社会的方式——尤其是美国，还有许多其他地方——其整体力量却在逼迫我做出那样的行为。它在将我定罪，或者本可以因我向他提供所需的帮助而将我定罪。
That day showed him that the border wall had seeped into his head. Yeah, the wall, the logic of the wall, the logic of immigration as we enforce it today, had gotten to my head so much such that I didn't provide help. A border is an idea so powerful that we never even have to see it to believe it, or believe in it. Global borders can be sites of peace and conflict, violence and celebration, opportunity and confinement. And borders as they exist today, which is to say increasingly
那一天让他明白，边境墙已经渗入了人们的脑海。是的，这堵墙，墙的逻辑，我们今天强行推行的移民逻辑，已经深深印在我的脑海里，以至于我没有提供帮助。边境是一个如此强大的概念，以至于我们甚至无需亲眼看到它，就会相信它，或是笃信不疑。全球的边境可能是和平与冲突、暴力与庆祝、机遇与禁锢的场所。而正如今天存在的边境——也就是说日益
militarized and clearly defined, they're actually a relatively recent political invention. It wasn't until the 20th century that strictly controlled national borders started to spread around the world. My own life has been shaped by borders. A violent border formation turned my grandparents into refugees. I myself have immigrated twice. And so, in an attempt to understand the weird and contradictory ways that borders sometimes operate, I wanted to talk to John. John's an immigration reporter, and he's also the author of the book, The Case for Open Borders. In his book, John writes about different borders around the world and how they work. And that's what our episode will be about today.
军事化且界限分明——其实是一个相对较近的政治发明。直到 20 世纪，严格控制的国境线才开始在世界各地蔓延。我自己的生活也曾被边境塑造。一次暴力的边境划定将我的祖父母变成了难民。我自己也移民过两次。因此，为了理解边境有时以诡异而矛盾的方式运作的现象，我想和约翰聊聊。约翰是一位移民记者，同时也是《开放边境的理由》（The Case for Open Borders）一书的作者。在他的书中，约翰写到了世界各地不同的边境及其运作方式。这也是我们今天这一期节目要讨论的内容。
Our first stop is Berlin, 1961. From 1961 to 1989, the Berlin Wall separated East and West Berlin. So a little bit of more context about the Berlin Wall. The official name of the wall when it was first starting to be built in 1961 is the Anti-Fascist Protection Rampart. This famous concrete barrier, topped with barbed wire, guarded with watchtowers and mines, it was built by communist East Germany to protect their territory from the West Germans. And yet, if anyone knows anything about the Berlin Wall, it was really stopping people
我们的第一站是 1961 年的柏林。从 1961 年到 1989 年，柏林墙将东西柏林隔离开来。关于柏林墙，我们再补充一点背景信息。1961 年这堵墙刚开始建造时，其官方名称是“反法西斯防卫工事”。这座著名的混凝土屏障顶部布满铁丝网，有瞭望塔和地雷把守，是共产主义东德为了保护其领土不受西德人侵害而建造的。然而，如果对柏林墙有所了解的话，它实际上是在阻止人们
from going the other direction. I think that's an interesting thing to note, that walls often have the opposite effect that they are purported to have. And if you look back deep into history, the very first sort of border demarcations weren't to keep people out, but they were to keep people in. The Berlin Wall was no exception. It's become too difficult, simply too dangerous. You see, you don't have to cross one wall, but two,
往另一个方向走。我认为这是一个值得注意的有趣现象，那就是墙往往会产生与它们宣称的相反的效果。如果你深入回顾历史，最初的某种边境划分并不是为了把人挡在外面，而是为了把人关在里面。柏林墙也不例外。这一切变得太困难，简直太危险了。你看，你不是只需翻过一堵墙，而是两堵，
and in some sections, as many as five. Concrete, three meters high, barbed wire fences, barricades, tripwires. There was also another unintended consequence of the wall. Something that people didn't realize until it was too late. The wall, it turned out, was making people sick. There is a concept that came out of an East German psychologist who coined the term Maurerkrankheit, or wall sickness, which is his understanding of how much this idea of cleaving a society in two creeped into people's heads. And it changed the way that they thought about themselves,
在某些路段甚至多达五堵。三米高的混凝土墙、铁丝网栅栏、路障、绊网。这堵墙还有一个意想不到的后果。人们直到为时已晚才意识到这一点。事实证明，这堵墙正在让人类生病。有一个概念源于一位东德心理学家，他创造了“柏林墙综合征”（Maurerkrankheit）这个词，以此来理解将一个社会劈为两半的想法是如何潜入人们脑海深处的。它改变了人们看待自己的方式，
it changed the way that they thought about and saw other people. Those affected with wall sickness were found on both sides of the Berlin Wall. According to psychologists, partially because of the wall, they displayed some combination of depression, anxiety, suicidal ideation, and paranoia. The closer they lived to the wall, the more acute their symptoms. So the Berlin Wall fell in 1989. And I think one of the important things to recognize is how it fell is I think people
改变了他们思考和看待他人的方式。患有柏林墙综合征的人在柏林墙的两侧都能找到。据心理学家称，部分由于这堵墙的影响，他们表现出抑郁、焦虑、自杀倾向和偏执等某种组合症状。他们住得离墙越近，症状就越严重。所以，柏林墙在 1989 年倒塌了。我认为需要认识到的重要一点之一，是它是如何倒塌的——我认为人们
started just basically seeing through it. What I mean is they were able to see through the logic of the border. There wasn't a bill that was passed or a new law that was passed. It was just popular discontent and protests. People just started gathering, just started just crossing the border. Thanks in part to mass protest and the increasing instability in East Germany at the time, restrictions at the border eventually loosened. Then, on November 9, 1989, the East German government opened the border, just before midnight. Hundreds of thousands of Germans from both sides immediately flocked to the wall, demanding that it be knocked down. Take a look at them. They've been there since last night.
开始基本上看穿了它。我的意思是，他们能够看透边境的逻辑。当时并没有通过什么法案或新法律。那只是一种民怨沸腾和抗议。人们只是开始聚集，开始直接跨越边境。部分由于大规模抗议以及当时东德日益加剧的不稳定局势，边境的限制最终放松了。然后，在 1989 年 11 月 9 日午夜前不久，东德政府开放了边境。来自两侧的数十万德国人立刻涌向柏林墙，要求把它推倒。看看他们。他们从昨天晚上就一直呆在那里。
They are here in the thousands. They are here in the thousands. They are here in the tens of thousands. Occasionally they shout, Die Maue muss weg, the wall must go. At that point, there was around a dozen international border walls throughout the world, and there was a huge celebration of openness. And yet, there's been an enormous retrenchment since then. There are somewhere around 80 border walls today. They're being hardened, ever more militarized. That's more border walls than ever before in human history.
他们成千上万地来到这里。他们成千上万地来到这里。他们成千上万地来到这里。他们偶尔高喊：“Die Maue muss weg”，意即这堵墙必须倒下。当时，全球大约有十来道国际边境墙，人们对开放状态进行了热烈的庆祝。然而，自那以后，边境墙出现了大规模的回潮。如今大约有 80 道边境墙。它们正在被加固，军事化程度日益加深。这比人类历史上任何时候的边境墙都要多。
And wall sickness is usually referenced as just that era, but I think that so many other places throughout the world today are infected with wall sickness. Countries worldwide have wrestled with borders. Where to place them, how to guard them. And John writes that borders tend to protect the idea of a country more than the country itself. Maybe it's with barbed wire fencing or a flag, a security checkpoint or a watchtower. Each border comes with its own flavor of pageantry.
柏林墙综合征通常被当作那个时代的专用词，但我认为当今世界上的许多其他地方也都感染了柏林墙综合征。世界各国一直在与边境作斗争。如何安置边境，如何守卫边境。约翰写道，边境往往是在捍卫国家的概念，而不是国家本身。也许是用铁丝网围栏、国旗、安检站或瞭望塔。每一种边境都带有其独特的盛装仪式。
Which brings us to our second stop, the Radcliffe line. Here at the border between the towns of Atari India and Vagha Pakistan, there's fences, there's police, there's also ice cream and face paint. You can buy carnival snacks and keychains with little machine guns on them. On either side of the border gate there are two huge stadiums, one for Indians and the other for Pakistanis. Since 1959, soldiers from both countries have staged an elaborate ceremony here, at the same time, every single day. It's a sort of choreographed dance battle. They strut back and forth like birds doing a mating call.
这就把我们带到了第二站——拉德克利夫线（Radcliffe Line）。在这里，印度阿塔里（Atari）镇和巴基斯坦瓦格（Wagha）镇的边境之间，有栅栏、警察，还有冰淇淋和面部彩绘。你可以买到嘉年华小吃和印有微型机枪图案的钥匙扣。边境大门的两侧是两座巨大的体育场，一座供印度人使用，另一座供巴基斯坦人使用。自 1959 年以来，两国士兵每天都在同一时间在这里举行精心排练的仪式。这是一种类似编排好的舞蹈对决。他们像求偶的鸟儿一样在场上大摇大摆地走来走去。
Every day they perform this ceremony. They flex their muscles at each other. They literally growl at each other. They do this sort of goose stepping, like high kicking march towards each other. They shake hands in a very manly fashion. They open the gates. They slam the gates. And there's lots of people who go
他们每天都进行这种仪式。他们互相展示肌肉。他们甚至对着彼此咆哮。他们迈着那种鹅步，像踢正步一样朝着对方大步走去。他们以非常男子汉的方式握手。他们打开大门。他们重重地关上大门。有许多人会来到
to this, mostly locals, I understand, and watch. On a typical day, the stadiums here are full. This is the most popular border crossing in the region, as in it's the one often written about in tourism magazines, but these military performances take place at various points along the long jagged line that separates India and Pakistan. A line which itself has a pretty bizarre history. It's an example of how most national borders were created in pretty random haphazard ways. This was the line of partition that divided these nations after, you know, centuries of imperial rule by the British.
这里观看，据我了解，大多数是当地人。在平常的日子里，这里的体育场座无虚席。这是该地区最受欢迎的边境口岸，旅游杂志上经常对其进行报道，但这些军事表演在分隔印度和巴基斯坦的那条漫长而曲折的边界线上的各个点都会上演。这条线本身有着相当离奇的历史。它是大多数国家边界以相当随机、杂乱无章的方式被创建的一个例子。这就是在经历了英国几个世纪的帝国统治之后，划分这些国家的分割线。
World War II left the British kind of broke, so they decided to abandon a number of their colonial projects, including British India. The plan was to form two new countries in their wake, India and Pakistan. It wasn't just demarcating the two countries, but part of the project that was happening at the same time was trying to divide the two countries specifically by religion. The concept was that the Hindu population of this region would go into India and the Muslim population would go into Pakistan. The British charged one man, Sir Cyril Radcliffe, with the task of drawing the line and creating the two nations.
第二次世界大战让英国人有点破产，于是他们决定放弃许多殖民项目，包括英属印度。当时的计划是在废墟上建立两个新国家，即印度和巴基斯坦。这不仅是划定两个国家，当时正在进行的计划的一部分，还试图明确地按宗教信仰来划分这两个国家。这个概念是，该地区的印度教人口将进入印度，而穆斯林人口将进入巴基斯坦。英国人将划定界线、建立两个国家的任务交给了一个人——西里尔·拉德克利夫爵士（Sir Cyril Radcliffe）。
Radcliffe was a British lawyer. And although he was declared the authority on carving out these two new countries, he knew next to nothing about the region and had never visited. Following nationalist riots in India, the British wanted to speed up their departure in 1947. And so Radcliffe was given just five weeks to draw the new border. That wasn't enough time for him to even get his hands on an updated map. And even though Britain intended to divide the countries along religious lines. Muslims, Hindus and Sikhs had lived for centuries side by side, all throughout the region.
拉德克利夫是一位英国律师。尽管他被宣布为开创这两个新国家的权威人物，但他对该地区几乎一无所知，也从未去过那里。随着印度国内爆发民族主义骚乱，英国人希望在 1947 年加快撤离步伐。因此，拉德克利夫仅被给了五周时间来画出新的边界。这甚至不够他拿到一张更新的地图。尽管英国人本意是按宗教信仰划分国家，但穆斯林、印度教徒和锡克教徒几个世纪以来一直在这整个地区的各个地方并肩生活在一起。
He studied maps and consulted some people, but he was given very short time to do this homework and almost willy-nilly just drew this line. Ultimately, the Radcliffe Line was drawn, and the British declared an independent India and Pakistan. Fearing mass protest, exact information of where the line would be was released to the public two days after the Declaration of Independence. This meant that millions of people celebrated independence without even knowing
他研究了地图并咨询了一些人，但他做这项功课的时间非常短，几乎是随心所欲地画下了这条线。最终，拉德克利夫线画好了，英国宣布印度和巴基斯坦独立。由于担心大规模抗议，关于边界具体位置的准确信息在独立宣言发表两天后才向公众公布。这意味着数百万人庆祝独立时，甚至不知道
which country they were in. Some towns raised both the Pakistani and Indian flags. But once word of the line had spread, millions suddenly became a religious minority, if they were Hindu or Sikh, living in the area that became Pakistan, or if they were Muslim, living in the area that became India. And for many of those people, that celebration quickly turned into horror. The amount of violence that occurred almost instantly was incredible. People were driven out of their homes and were subject to mass communal violence and rioting. I think the highest estimate is around two million people died as a direct result of this partition.
自己身处哪个国家。一些城镇同时升起了巴基斯坦和印度的国旗。但一旦边界的消息传开，如果印度教徒或锡克教徒生活在变成巴基斯坦的地区，或者穆斯林生活在变成印度的地区，数百万人突然就成了宗教少数群体。对于其中的许多人来说，这种庆祝活动迅速演变成了一场噩梦。几乎瞬间爆发的暴力事件数量惊人。人们被赶出家园，遭受大规模的族群暴力和骚乱。我认为最高的估计是，大约有两百万人直接死于这场分治。
Cyril Radcliffe's line, that smooth stroke of pen, it suddenly put about 15 million people in the wrong place, making it the largest forced migration in the world. This is one of the most stark examples, but there's so many throughout the world. If you look at the current way that the world is divided into nation-states, over 40% of all borders were drawn by Britain and France. They were just drawn on a map and imposed upon the populations. And sometimes that kind of works out or doesn't have a huge effect. But in the case of India and Pakistan, I mean, the effects were devastating and truly, I think, hard to grasp.
西里尔·拉德克利夫的那条线，那笔挥洒自如的线条，突然把大约 1500 万人放错了地方，使其成为世界上最大规模的被迫迁徙。这是一个最鲜明的例子，但世界上还有很多这样的例子。如果你看看当前世界被划分成民族国家的现状，超过 40% 的边界是由英国和法国画的。它们只是被画在地图上，然后强加给当地的人口。有时这种做法效果还行，或者没有产生巨大的影响。但在印度和巴基斯坦的案例中，我的意思是，其影响是毁灭性的，而且老实说，我认为很难理解。
It's telling that after drawing the line, Radcliffe burned all of his paperwork. He left India and even declined to receive payment from the British government for the job. Much of the India-Pakistan border is fenced and lit up by the Indian government, 1, 1200 miles of bright floodlights making the line visible from outer space. It's one of the most contested borders in the world. And yet, the Atarivaga border crossing can also be a place to have a picnic and watch some circus-like fun. It's an absolute contradiction.
耐人寻味的是，在画完这条线后，拉德克利夫烧毁了他所有的文件。他离开印度，甚至拒绝接受英国政府为这项工作支付的报酬。印巴边界的大部分地区都被印度政府安装了围栏并点亮，1200 英里长的耀眼泛光灯使得这条边界线从外太空都能看得见。这是世界上争议最大的边境之一。然而，阿塔里-瓦格边境口岸也可以是一个野餐和观看马戏般乐趣的地方。这绝对是一个矛盾。
One that John says isn't so unusual. And much like this border, John says all borders are selectively permeable. They are closed down to certain people, but they are very open to the flows of capital, to the trading of arms, all sorts of other things. So there's always that sort of dissonance and always that clash at every borderline throughout the world. It's in Kashmir where the Radcliffe Line stops.
约翰说，这种矛盾并不罕见。和这个边境一样，约翰说所有的边境都是选择性渗透的。它们对某些人关闭，但对资本流动、武器交易以及各种其他事物却非常开放。因此，世界上每一个边界线都始终存在着那种不和谐与冲突。拉德克利夫线在克什米尔戛然而止。
The British left that disputed territory for India and Pakistan to resolve on their own in 1947. And they immediately went to war over it. Lately, a war over borders is once again at the center of conflict between the two nuclear-armed countries. And for 12 days, the daily theatrical rivalry at this border crossing was put on pause.
英国人将这个有争议的领土留给印度和巴基斯坦在 1947 年自行解决。而他们立刻为此爆发了战争。最近，一场关于边境的战争再次成为这两个拥有核武器的国家之间冲突的核心。在长达 12 天的时间里，这个边境口岸每日上演的戏剧性对抗暂停了。
The performance has since resumed, but now with some key changes. This time, the gates do not open and there is no handshake. We'll be back after this. We're back with producer Lasha Madon. A border is a line that can shift and bend, and is often a lot less rigid than we might think. John Washington, author of the book The Case for Open Borders, writes that if
此后表演恢复了，但现在有了一些关键的改变。这一次，大门没有打开，也没有握手。广告之后我们将继续播出。欢迎回到节目，我是制作人拉夏·马东。边境是一条可以移动和弯曲的线，通常比我们想象的要灵活得多。《开放边境的理由》一书的作者约翰·华盛顿写道，如果
history is any guide, national borders are always moving, often conveniently closing shut behind those who enforce them. With that, we've arrived at our third stop, Australia 2001. There's a really momentous case, both in international law and for Australia itself, in 2001. A small fishing boat crammed with 433 asylum seekers was on its way to Australia when the boat's engine failed in international waters. The people aboard, who were mostly from Afghanistan, were rescued by a nearby container ship. The ship's captain was shocked by the health conditions of some people aboard, and he began
历史可以作为参考的话，国家边界总是在移动，而且往往在那些执行边界政策的人身后悄悄关闭。伴随着这一点，我们迎来了第三站——2001 年的澳大利亚。2001 年发生了一个无论在国际法还是对澳大利亚本身而言都具有重大意义的案例。一艘挤满了 433 名寻求庇护者的微型渔船在前往澳大利亚的途中，船的发动机在国际水域发生故障。船上的人大部分来自阿富汗，被附近的一艘集装箱船救起。船长对船上一些人的健康状况感到震惊，于是开始
to sail to the closest port for safety. And they ended up on Christmas Island, which is an island about a thousand miles off the coast of mainland Australia, but is claimed by the country of Australia. And so when they got to Christmas Island, they were not allowed to dock because Australia was really nervous about the fact that if they touched land, they would be able to levy an asylum claim and they would have to welcome them in, hear out their claims, and then maybe even grant them if they were legitimate. So the asylum seekers waited in limbo.
驶向最近的港口以保证安全。他们最终到达了圣诞岛，这是一个距离澳大利亚本土海岸约一千英里的岛屿，但由澳大利亚主权声索。因此，当他们到达圣诞岛时，他们被禁止靠岸，因为澳大利亚非常担心一旦他们触及陆地，他们就能够提出庇护申请，而澳大利亚将不得不欢迎他们进来，听取他们的申请，甚至在申请合法的情况下批准这些申请。因此，寻求庇护者陷入了进退维谷的境地。
They remained on board the vessel near Christmas Island while the Australian government argued over their fate. Their conditions grew more and more bleak. Some of the migrants began a hunger strike. People were sick. People were on the verge of dying. The ship's captain kept trying to get Australia's attention. On the fourth desperate day, he started sailing towards mainland Australia.
在澳大利亚政府就他们的命运争论不休的同时，他们仍然留在圣诞岛附近的船上。他们的处境变得越来越凄凉。一些难民开始绝食抗议。人们生病了。人们处于垂死边缘。船长不断试图引起澳大利亚的注意。在绝望的第四天，他开始向澳大利亚本土驶去。
A high seas standoff with the captain of a Norwegian freighter who picked up more than 400 asylum seekers from a sinking boat and attempted to enter Australian waters. The government refused deploying SAS troops in a show of military force. Besides sending military to prevent the ship from sailing any closer, the Australian government got to work, quickly passing the first of a series of laws, suddenly giving them the power to refuse entry to asylum seekers arriving by boat. And this is an example of what is called a turn back. Australia redirected the asylum seekers to other islands, including a tiny island country called Nauru.
一艘挪威货轮的船长从一艘下沉的船上接走了 400 多名寻求庇护者，并试图进入澳大利亚水域，这引发了一场公海对峙。政府拒绝放行，并部署了特种空勤团（SAS）以展示军事力量。除了派遣军队阻止船只继续航行之外，澳大利亚政府迅速行动，接连通过了一系列法律的第一部分，突然赋予他们拒绝乘船抵达的寻求庇护者入境的权力。这就是所谓的“遣返”（turn back）。澳大利亚将寻求庇护者重新安置到其他岛屿，包括一个名为瑙鲁的微型岛国。
Which is this guano-covered, incredibly hot, isolated island where they detained these asylum seekers. Nauru was once a country rich in natural resources, but after being mined by a series of corrupt governments, it was left desperate for money. And so, when Australia approached them and said, we want to build a detention center on your land, it wasn't really in a position to refuse. Refugees trying to get to Australia would be redirected to Nauru and have their applications for asylum to Australia processed there. And what they decided to do besides deflect their claim is imprison them. Actually, this was the first establishment of a detention center on this, like, offshore island.
这是一个被鸟粪覆盖、炎热无比、极其孤立的岛屿，他们在那里关押这些寻求庇护者。瑙鲁曾是一个自然资源丰富的国家，但在遭到一连串腐败政府的开采后，变得极度缺钱。因此，当澳大利亚找到他们并说“我们想在你们的土地上建立一个拘留中心”时，他们实际上没有立场拒绝。试图前往澳大利亚的难民将被重新安置到瑙鲁，他们在澳大利亚的庇护申请也将在那里处理。他们除了拒绝接受他们的申请之外，还决定将他们监禁。实际上，这是首次在这样的离岸岛屿上建立拘留中心。
And this is a practice that Australia has been doing ever since. What began as a hurried political response to the arrival of that one boat in 2001 grew into a series of permanent immigration policies. Australia called this new set of laws the Pacific Solution. The Pacific Solution involved something else, too. Something kind of extreme. And what they decided to do was actually to excise Christmas Island, as well as a few other islands, from official Australian national territory.
这也是澳大利亚自那以后一直在实行的做法。最初作为对 2001 年那艘船到达的仓促政治回应，最终演变成了一系列永久性的移民政策。澳大利亚将这一套新法律称为“太平洋解决方案”（Pacific Solution）。太平洋解决方案还包含其他内容。某种程度上相当极端的行动。他们决定实际上将圣诞岛以及其他几个岛屿从澳大利亚官方国家领土中剔除。
So that way, if any Afghani or any other person made it to Christmas Island in the future, they couldn't ask for asylum. Just like that, the Australian border was changed. The new policy was backdated to two and a half hours before the refugees entered Australian waters. This way, the official memory of the arrival of those people to Australia had been erased. The asylum seekers had never really been in Australia at all, at least not in any way that could be of benefit to them. The broad point is that the way that people who are trying to keep away migrants talk about borders is that they are these immovable, psychosank lines that are deeply rooted in history.
这样一来，如果未来有任何阿富汗人或其他任何人抵达圣诞岛，他们都无法申请庇护。就这样，澳大利亚的边界被改变了。新政策甚至追溯到难民进入澳大利亚水域前两个半小时生效。通过这种方式，那些人抵达澳大利亚的官方记忆就被抹去了。这些寻求庇护者其实从来没有真正踏上过澳大利亚的土地，至少没有以任何对他们有利的方式踏上过。总的观点是，那些试图将移民拒之门外的人在谈论边境时，总是将其描述为不可动摇、神圣不可侵犯、植根于历史的线条。
But they're not. They are malleable and they are constantly being moved. And that Australia was willing to move its border to protect its border, I think is a really telling example. After the 2001 incident, a detention center was built on Christmas Island too. It became known as the island on which a hundred million crabs roam free, but refugees live behind bars. In the case for open borders, this is John Washington's argument. People should be able to move and migrate wherever they want and need to.
但它们并非如此。它们是可塑的，并且在不断变动。我认为，澳大利亚为了保护其边界而甘愿移动边界，就是一个极具说明意义的例子。2001 年事件发生后，圣诞岛上也建立了一个拘留中心。它被称为“百万只螃蟹自由漫步，但难民却生活在铁窗之后”的岛屿。在《开放边境的理由》中，这就是约翰·华盛顿的论点。人们应该能够随心所欲地四处迁移和移民。
That instead of criminalizing people for crossing a border, we should instead fear the society in which we deny a desperate person aid, leaving them stranded on the side of a desert road, much like John did with that young man years ago in the Anza Borrego desert. To put it even more simply, John says we should open our borders. Open borders is not no borders. I do think it makes sense to draw some sort of line around a community in which you say that these people are part of this Commonwealth and these people are part of the other. I think that's just, you know, political organizing.
我们不应该将越境行为定为犯罪，相反，我们应该警惕那种拒绝向绝望者提供援助、任由他们滞留在沙漠路边（正如约翰多年前在安扎-博雷戈沙漠对那个年轻人所做的那样）的社会。用更简单的话来说，约翰说我们应该开放边界。开放边境并不等于没有边界。我确实认为，围绕一个共同体画一条线是有道理的，你在其中宣称这些人是这个共同体的一部分，而那些人是另一个共同体的一部分。我认为这只是，你知道的，政治组织方式。
But the presumption would be, in the version of Open Borders I'm talking about, that that line can be crossed and anyone can do it and they don't need a compelling reason to do so. This idea might sound radical now, but it wasn't always that way. Even Ronald Reagan called for what sounds like an open border between the U.S. and Mexico at a Republican presidential primary debate in 1980. Rather than making them or talking about putting up a fence, why don't we work out some recognition of our mutual problems, make it possible for them to come here legally with a
但在我所说的开放边境版本中，其前提是这条线是可以跨越的，任何人都可以这样做，而且他们不需要一个令人信服的理由。这个想法现在听起来可能很激进，但过去并非如此。甚至在 1980 年的一次共和党总统初选辩论中，罗纳德·里根也曾呼吁建立听起来像美墨之间开放边境的政策。与其制造他们或者谈论建立栅栏，为什么我们不设法承认我们的共同问题，让他们有可能合法地来到这里并获得
work permit. And then while they're working and earning here, they pay taxes here. And when they go on to go back, they can go back and they can cross and open the border both ways. Not long after, The Wall Street Journal called for a five word amendment to the Constitution. There shall be open borders. And less than a decade ago, Democrats running in their party's presidential primary were competing over who is more pro-immigrant.
工作许可。然后当他们在这里工作和赚钱时，他们在这里纳税。当他们准备回去时，他们可以回去，并且可以双向跨越和开放边界。不久之后，《华尔街日报》呼吁对宪法进行一项五个字的修正案。那就是：应当开放边界。就在不到十年前，在其党内总统初选中竞选的民主党人还在争论谁对移民更友善。
But times have changed. I think just reminding people of some of those things shows that it's not as far-fetched as it might seem given our current political climate. John says there are many reasons the spirit of open borders should return. There are ethical reasons. There are also economic reasons. Because immigrants contribute positively to a country's economic growth. Any economist worth their fiscal salt and has looked at this issue knows that
但时代变了。我认为只需提醒人们记住其中的一些事情，就会表明，鉴于我们当前的政治气候，它并没有想象中那么异想天开。约翰说，开放边境精神应当回归是有很多原因的。有道德上的原因。也有经济上的原因。因为移民对一个国家的经济增长做出了积极贡献。任何一个财政上称职、研究过这一问题的经济学家都知道，
migration is good for receiving communities and they are overall a huge boon to economies both local and regional and of course national as well. In 2017 the National Department of Health and Human Services commissioned a study on the fiscal effects of refugees and asylees in the US. What researchers found wasn't aligned with what the Trump administration was looking for, and the study was buried,
移民对接收社区是有益的，他们总体上对地方、区域乃至国家的经济都是巨大的福音。2017 年，美国卫生与公众服务部（National Department of Health and Human Services）委托进行了一项关于难民和受庇护者对美国财政影响的研究。研究人员发现的结果并不符合特朗普政府的预期，因此该研究被掩盖了，
though eventually leaked to the New York Times. The study found that from 2005 to 2014, the US refugee and asylee population paid $63 billion more in taxes than what they received in benefits. Here's the thing. Humans have always migrated. And they likely always will. If you look back far enough, tales of migration are central to so many of our religions, literature, and our family histories.
不过最终还是被泄露给了《纽约时报》。该研究发现，从 2005 年到 2014 年，美国难民和受庇护者群体缴纳的税款比他们获得的福利多出 630 亿美元。事情是这样的。人类一直在迁徙。而且他们很可能永远都会迁徙。如果你回溯得够远，你会发现迁徙的故事是我们许多宗教、文学以及家族史的核心。
And John says it's essential to look at migration into the U.S. through this lens as well. That people are always going to want to move, and even more so in the context of climate change. Trying to stop it isn't only inhumane, it's also expensive and a little futile. Just look at the sheer numbers. I mean, since the United States has really put in force all of its most robust and most militarized and most draconian immigration enforcement mechanisms,
约翰说，通过这种视角来看待向美国的移民同样至关重要。人们总是想要四处迁移，在气候变化的背景下更是如此。试图阻止这种趋势不仅不人道，而且代价高昂且有点徒劳。看看绝对数字就知道了。我的意思是，自从美国真正实施了其所有最强硬、最军事化、最严厉的移民执法机制以来，
the numbers of people crossing have remained steady or have continued to go up. John says that if your ultimate goal is to stop people from moving, well, he doesn't think that's possible. But either way, a border wall isn't going to be so effective at keeping people out. I think walls do slow people down, but most folks can cut through them, can hire someone to cut through them, can walk around them, tunnel under them, or climb a ladder over them. The reason that under the first Trump administration, they strung up hundreds of miles of concertina wire along the wall, the reason Greg Abbott of Texas put out buoys across the Rio Grande with these like razor blades basically between them, was not that it's so effective, but it's
越境人数一直保持稳定或持续上升。约翰说，如果你的最终目标是阻止人们移动，好吧，他认为这并不可能。但无论如何，边境墙在把人挡在外面方面并不会那么有效。我认为墙确实会减慢人们的速度，但大多数人都可以切断它们，雇人切断它们，绕过它们，在它们下面挖地道，或者用梯子翻过去。在特朗普第一任期内，他们在墙边架设了数百英里的蛇腹形铁丝网，得克萨斯州的格雷格·阿博特（Greg Abbott）在格兰德河上放置浮标，基本上在浮标之间安装了剃须刀片，原因并不是这有多么有效，而是为了
to send a message. On the other hand, the border wall alongside hardened internal immigration policies are actually discouraging people to leave the United States after they enter. That trend of coming and going, it's called circular migration, and it used to be very common in the U.S. Over the last 20 years, as we've really ramped up border and immigration enforcement, the amount of circular migration has plummeted. People would come to the United States not with the intention
发出一个信号。另一方面，边境墙加上强硬的内部移民政策，实际上正在阻碍人们在进入美国后离开。这种来来往往的趋势被称为“循环移民”，过去在美国非常普遍。在过去的 20 年里，随着我们真正加大了边境和移民执法力度，循环移民的数量已经骤降。人们来到美国并不是为了
of permanently staying here, but they would come, they would try to work a couple years, they'd make some money, and they would leave. But now, because it's so dangerous and so costly to come, that people realize that it's not worth the danger and the money to go and come back more than once. So they get stuck here. Just like with the Berlin Wall, the militarized American border is unintentionally keeping many people in.
在这里永久定居，而是来这里尝试工作几年，赚点钱，然后离开。但现在，因为来这里的危险性太高、代价太大，人们意识到冒险和花钱来回跑不止一次是不划算的。所以他们被困在了这里。就像柏林墙一样，军事化的美国边境在无意中将许多人留在了境内。
Until very recently, we did not talk about borders the way we do today. Before the 1990s, there was almost no physical infrastructure along America's southern border. Now there are about 700 miles of fences and walls stretching along the line that separates Mexico and the U.S. And here's one more fact. The relative age of the U.S.-Mexico border wall right now is about 30 years old. The same age that the Berlin Wall was when it fell. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Lashma Donne and edited by Delaney Hall.
直到最近，我们对边境的讨论方式还与今天不同。在 20 世纪 90 年代之前，美国南部边境几乎没有任何实体基础设施。现在，沿着分隔墨西哥和美国的边界线，大约有 700 英里的栅栏和墙壁延伸开来。还有一个事实。美墨边境墙的相对年龄现在大约是 30 岁。这与柏林墙倒塌时的年龄相同。本周的《99% Invisible》由拉什·马东（Lashma Donne）制作，德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）编辑。
Mixed by Martine Gonzalez. Music by Swan Real. Fact-checking by Graham Hayesha. Special thanks this week to John Washington, author of The Case for Open Borders. Cathy Tu is our executive producer. Kurt Kolstad is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Chris Berube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivienne Leigh, Joe Rosenberg, Kelly Prime, Jacob Medina Gleason, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of his logo was created by Stefan Lawrence.
由马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martine Gonzalez）混音。音乐由斯旺·里尔（Swan Real）创作。事实核查由格雷厄姆·海沙（Graham Hayesha）完成。本周特别感谢《开放边境的理由》一书的作者约翰·华盛顿。凯西·图（Cathy Tu）是我们的执行制片人。库尔特·科尔斯塔德（Kurt Kolstad）是数字总监。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·贝鲁布（Chris Berube）、杰森·德莱昂（Jason DeLeon）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、维维安·利（Vivienne Leigh）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、凯利·普赖姆（Kelly Prime）、雅各布·梅迪纳·格利森（Jacob Medina Gleason），以及我，罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。99% 的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作。
We are part of the SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building in beautiful Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites. We're mostly on Blue Sky, as well as our own Discord server. There's a link to that, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们是 SiriusXM 播客家族的一部分，总部现在位于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市区北部六个街区处的潘多拉大厦。你可以在所有常规社交媒体网站上找到我们。我们主要在 Blue Sky 上活动，也有我们自己的 Discord 服务器。在 99PI.org 上可以找到该链接以及 99PI 以往的所有单集。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。